right we got ourselves a clothing
sponsorship before we get started I want
to thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by true classic
because we dudes come in all shapes and
sizes small Big Skinny strong but all of
us when looking for a t-shirt are just
just looking for a few things that feels
comfortable it fits right it makes us
look good and that Quest can feel like a
bit of a unicorn hunt and can get really
expensive that's why when I got this
pack of true Classic t-shirts I was like
oh These are nice they're comfortable
I'll do this and they don't just have
T-shirts they have a myriad of men's
clothing Polo's workout shirts that
still have that same flattering fit and
they have a pack Builder on their
website allowing you to custom bundle
all their essential products allowing
you to save more on top of the savings
you're about to get from the promo code
I'm about to give you so click the link
below go to trueclassictees.com use
promo code Johns get yourself 25 off
your order free shipping is included on
purchase over a hundred dollars and it's
risk-free with a 30-day return policy
all right we're looking good we're
feeling good back on with the jacket
Shazam let's do this
[Music]
so Black Adam is a DC eu's film about
the character Black Adam eight years
after it was announced that The Rock was
going to be Black Adam I thought this
got mothballed and it was like oh this
is still coming out that's cool so you
know in the movie Shazam how the wizard
was like oh there was this one other one
oopsie Daisy this is that Wizards
champion before Shazam played by The
Rock and now after being gone for
thousands of years he's back the JSA
come in they're like hey we don't we
don't kill people look you got the rock
shooting lightning from his fingertips
and killing bad guys you know this is
kind of it's what we're clocking on for
and right off the gate that's what
carries the movie The Rock as Black Adam
is just having so much fun being black
Adam at cinemacon Dwayne Johnson was
talking about what they were going for
they were like we kind of wanted to do a
Dirty Harry thing rather than just make
him the bad guy I thought they pulled
that off well and as someone who was
thinking why didn't they just bring in
the rock as Black Adam and Shazam too
why is Shazam two doing something
different would have made a perfect time
to drop the Rock in there and have him
fight I'm actually glad they didn't do
that I'm glad we we got
this but he's toasting douchebags the
entire movie so you're like I mean I'm
not against him there are some things in
this movie that you've seen in fact
other movies I was gonna say other
movies but other DC EU movies as well
like you know he's back after thousands
of years so it's kind of a fish out of
water scenario kind of like they did in
Wonder Woman only with killing more
people but they're using the fish out of
water in tandem with the killing people
and that's not really socially
acceptable thing it's just doing it well
what can I say I laugh at that also like
what they did with Black Adam and the
citizens of condoc in here there was a
real sense of the citizens being like
well I know you don't like them but
well he just got [ __ ] done so they could
have gone farther with that than they
did in the movie but it'd appreciate it
now this movie even from the trailers
you might have had a concern it was a
concern I had going into the movie which
was this movie looks pretty packed looks
like there's a lot going on it's a JSA
movie it's a Black Adam movie Dr Fates
in it that's his own element I feel like
a whole movie could be dedicated to him
so I'm gonna count him as a third thing
the movie's doing and if you have those
fears going into this movie this movie
will not make those fears go away yeah
it's a jam-packed movie they're doing a
lot sometimes to its detriment but in
general I see why they use the JSA
because it's like okay who can go up
against Black Adam if you don't want
Black Adam to be the villain Justice
League would Eclipse Black Adam in his
own movie Suicide Squad there's no one
there that can go Toe to Toe with Black
Adam physically plus Suicide Squad to be
like you kill people too awesome with on
with the Mayhem let's just bloodbath
this place look at that you got to bring
in dollar store Justice League who won't
Eclipse Black Adam him in his own movie
but can still go toe-to-toe with him and
is able to be like no we don't kill
people that's not how Heroes do it
unless you're the Justice League
they've killed people so in large part
the JSA does work in this movie but you
have to know who these characters are
they give you the lowdown on a couple of
them but they don't tell you jack [ __ ]
about Hawkman I will say there was some
noticeable CGI as well when it came to
the JSA especially Hawkman I mean dude
has wings that spread out it's like a
whole thing just a lot more CGI with him
now as much as I like the JSA and Black
Adam butting heads in this movie The
Thing it poses a problem with is well
what do we do for the last act so you
just have to make
think of the fears what fears do you
have in a comic book movie you ever
think to yourself oh man we're past that
phase right we're past that phase of
super CGI nothing boss that Sprouts out
of nowhere that well we're not past it
yet I guess yeah it's exactly the last
act CGI [ __ ] you might be afraid of
for this movie it's in here and the
villain I didn't give two shits about I
didn't cares like when the last act
happens the Fun's over the fun of this
movie isn't oh are they gonna stop the
villain who came out of nowhere for the
end fight of the movie the fun of this
movie is Dwayne Johnson as Black Adam
wiping out baddies with no remorse
whatsoever but still doing it with some
sense of moral code but the JSA being
like that's not how we do it and
conflict ensues there that's where the
movie's in its Goldilocks zone in the
end is the movie perfect no is it
polished absolutely not is it fun [ __ ]
yeah the movie started out a little
shaky it's doing that Exposition dump
with the voiceover thing not that that's
always bad this felt like they had a
three hour cut of the film and they were
like we cannot have this be three hours
so we're gonna go ahead and take that
first hour trim it down to 15 minutes do
voice over
that'll be the setup like the movie's
book ended with [ __ ] but in the
middle there there's a sweet spot some
really fun stuff and to its core there's
actually a compelling family story that
is here and what I felt was a fulfilling
Arc revolving around the character Black
Adam I thought Black Adam was a fun time
no alcohol required all right so Black
Adam have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]